all right so we're gonna um just run
down in this
about a mile in the back
and then we'll walk down quiet and
they're down by the creek
it's 7 30 a.m and tony dinicola is
preparing for an important day in a
battle against an invasive species
he's tracking wild boars that have been
destroying the land today it brings him
to this farm in south carolina so
if you look
throughout the woods here everything's
kind of toughed up turned up they're
looking for earthworms insects acorns
that might be remnant from the fall but
when they're doing this in your crop
fields that's a big problem and why we
really need to catch every pig in the
area
tony and the property owner set up a
trap deep into the woods this morning
they're checking to see if they caught
any feral swine
pigs are native in europe and throughout
asia however in the united states or
north america they are not pigs have
found their way to canada they're
invasive there they're invasive
throughout central and south america so
literally they are a worldwide pest
species and so the significance of
developing new methods to manage them
is quite critical
tony a wildlife ecologist runs a
non-profit that deals with invasive
species now one of his focuses is on
what the u.s department of agriculture
calls the feral swine bomb these wild
pigs pose a serious threat to the
economy human health and they're an
ecological disaster there's many facets
to their behavior and activity that
create both health and economic impacts
on humans for starters there are
millions of them eating their way
through roughly 40 states causing about
2.5 billion dollars in u.s property and
crop damage and it's happening in canada
as well it's a substantial amount of
money it can make or break a farm year
rachel sharpe has lost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to feral pigs this
is some of the seed after it's bagged in
allendale south carolina she manages
sharp and sharp certified seed a farm
that has been in her family for three
generations
they specialize in growing seeds like
soybeans and corn there's soybeans all
over the floor so be careful i can't
tell how many times i've fallen or
popped my behind after slipping on one
the family farm was hit hard in 2019.
rachel and her father were taking a
drive to check the corn they had just
planted when they discovered it had been
ruined i said oh my gosh you know what
happened and he said this is feral hog
damage we ended up replanting that field
and literally i bet it was 10 days later
it was gone again we lost 220 acres of
corn that year to feral hog damage they
are suffering significant financial
losses year after year it is so
disheartening to spend so much time and
so much money putting a crop in the
ground and then seeing it come up and
look okay and go back the next day and
it's completely mowed down it's a really
bad problem and i do often feel like i'm
fighting a losing battle
during our visit she took us on a tour
of their sprawling 3000 acres to a spot
where her dad seeking a solution dug a
ditch
i didn't realize how deep he had dug it
either but look at that thing
he was serious rachel and her family
have been doing everything in their
power to keep the wild hogs away so far
the pigs keep reproducing and destroying
we don't want the hogs out here we don't
want them in anybody's backyard i don't
want to risk anything ever happen in
this place i mean i love it and i want
the next generation to be able to love
it one of the reasons they're so
dangerous is because they're so
difficult to get rid of hunting might
seem like an obvious solution but in
reality it's only exacerbated the
problem so some states and provinces
have either banned or have rules
governing wild hog hunting there's never
been a demonstrated situation where
recreational hunting can control feral
pigs in fact populations continue to
increase so unless you're systematically
and professionally trapping and removing
pigs in the landscape you'll never catch
up that's because pigs are smart and if
you don't kill the entire group the ones
that survive can move locations and
teach their offspring how to avoid
hunters i think somebody said pigs are
the fourth smartest mammal but they're
probably smarter than about 80 percent
of the humans would be my best guess
so what'll happen is somebody's shooting
at them and they start seeing hunters in
tree stands if an animal has a bad
experience then they learn to avoid it
so their offspring can cue into those
behaviors and say hey you know mom says
this isn't a good situation
come on boys
in canada jurgen praichus saw the
problem looming decades ago come on be
easier for domestic pork producers like
him curbing the feral swine growth is
crucial to keeping his business and the
canadian economy afloat
the 73 year old is part owner of a pig
farm in mayor thorpe alberta jurgen says
he warned government officials in the
1980s of course i was pooh-poohed and
told that this was never going to be an
issue
wild boars were introduced into canada
in the 80s and 90s to diversify the
livestock industry over the years there
have been stories of boar producers
letting their stock loose while others
escaped and were able to multiply if you
have wild pigs like this come onto your
yard and then whatever disease they may
be carrying transmits to our animals
then it puts
the whole industry at risk feral pigs
can be a host to a list of diseases and
parasites like pseudorabies and the
hepatitis e virus one in particular is
called brucella it's a bacterial disease
and it can infect both humans and pigs
trichinolosis lives in the muscle of
pigs and can infect humans as well if
they ingest undercooked
pork brian stevens is a wildlife
pathologist at the university of guelph
in ontario
what is the threat to our domestic pig
population so asf is african swine fever
that is a viral disease it's a disease
that is specific to pigs so thankfully
it's not something we have to worry
about infecting humans it has a high
mortality rate and it can have
devastating effects on the domestic
swine population because if that disease
gets into a barn it can just go in and
wipe out a vast majority of the pigs in
a short amount of time
african swine fever or asf is worldwide
the dominican republic reported its
first case of it in domestic swine in
2021. some farmed pigs in europe have it
too but it's most prominent in their
wild boar population you're going to
have devastating effects for the economy
not to mention the livelihood of all of
these pork producers is going to be
potentially destroyed by this disease
making its way in so far canada and the
u.s have not registered a case but it's
a threat if there was a case of asf in
either the wild or domestic pig
population the borders would close
to give you a sense of how significant
the losses could be the canadian
government says the pork industry
generates upwards of 24 billion to the
economy every year
our biggest fear is african swine fever
it'll devastate a farm that may be like
ours that's now third generation
it could bankrupt it and many others
with it
[Music]
back in south carolina tony di nicola is
getting closer to the trap he set from a
distance he can see quite a few wild
pigs have been captured under the net
40. trapping is the most effective tool
to get the highest percentage of animals
rapidly but you have to do it
strategically to ensure you're going to
get all the pigs that are coming in that
location
part of his technique is using kennel
corn as bait to entice the hogs
but tony is doing something different
this time around he's been working on a
special type of feed to attract wild
pigs but keep other woodland creatures
at bay in some areas you have disease
transmission risks amongst deer we have
chronic wasting disease here as you do
in canada and so we don't want to
congregate deer unnecessarily so he's
been mixing deer repellent into the corn
to see if they skip the meal but the
swine still find it enticing we've got
two that were tested one is bone meal
and then the other is putrified egg
solids what we've shown now over 11 days
is many of those deer have just given up
coming in they're just like the heck
with it i'm not gonna eat these treated
corn piles the most important thing was
we didn't have any reluctance of pigs
eating the the treated corn so we're on
it we're in a good place we'll probably
do more advanced trials where it would
be publishable
if tony's trials are successful it could
be a very useful tool in mitigating the
spread of wild pigs across canada and
the u.s because at this point it appears
the idea of elimination doesn't seem
possible
and so trying to control the current
population might be the only option to
prevent catastrophic ecological and
economic damage we're only baiting one
spot in the state of south carolina and
we caught 40 pigs and you could probably
go a mile down the road and catch
another 40 pigs their abundance in this
landscape and throughout the southeast
you don't want that in canada you don't
want in other ecologically sensitive or
agriculturally important environments
because once they get embedded and
they're that abundant it's very very
difficult to reverse that trend